so you're just going to reveal that
Emperor Palpatine is alive in the
opening credits it just makes me go like
this impossible perhaps the archives are
incomplete why didn't they just reveal
Palpatine in the last Jedi imagined
during the throne room scene Snoke dies
and then a clone of Snoke walks in
explaining his resurrection that was
made possible by Palpatine that would
have been a pretty crazy twist instead
of just seeing him in a test-tube her
like five seconds
also Palpatine could even be a clone
this would explain how he survived the
return of the Jedi the whole concept of
cloning being used by system is very
interesting but this is basically the
only line from the movie that goes into
it cloning he's been planning his
revenge they drop this immediately and
we go straight into race scavenger hunt
that lasts about an hour so Emperor
Palpatine just has a fleet of 1,000
destroyers under the ice where did he
even get the resources to build that
many ships without anyone knowing about
it in the galaxy that'll get you this
rich selling weapons to the first order
so everyone on Kent subbytes should know
about the emperor's new fleet if they
sound hook up the first order with Star
Destroyers and weapons at this point I'm
just assuming that Emperor Palpatine was
rolling in dough also why does the
Lightning sound like nails on chalkboard
so in this scene they are getting some
Intel from someone who works in the
first order what isn't explained is the
fact that a bunch of Thai fighters show
up with no explanation they're just
there for action and the scene where Poe
is flying in dodging buildings he looks
directly at Chewie instead of where he
is going further demonstration of him
being a great pilot
I like how rageous assumes that this
alien speaks English and the alien
somehow just knows her language but
can't speak it
also these speeder bike type vehicles go
from levitation to ground it this
evolving just backwards only if she knew
how to levitate them out of there when
you're sinking in the sand you said I
never told you I'll tell you later
it's already before still I don't know
why they keep telling the audience that
Finn knows something about Rey and to
have him never say it it doesn't really
make sense he probably knows that raise
a Palpatine but I feel like he only
knows that to give us character more
relevance besides that he doesn't do
anything and just shouts character names
and random things
[Music]
that's some great character development
in the force awakens he went from being
a stormtrooper to helping their
resistance and in the last Jedi he went
from being a selfish coward to a heroic
hero who wanted to sacrifice himself he
should have just died in the last Jedi
because he doesn't do anything in the
rise of a Skywalker going back to the
quicksand scene it just so happens that
under the quicksand was exactly where
they needed to go
it seems pretty convenient especially
when that dagger could have been
anywhere in the desert after did they
get off to desert planet they have some
time to cool down and it's revealed that
they are being tracked by the Knights of
Ren it doesn't make sense as to why the
Knights of Ren didn't just seize their
ship on the spot because they end up
losing them on the planet they were
going to so they're just completely
useless there's an art to back up your
memory
[Music]
remember a restoration complete why is
there only like five stormtroopers in
this entire hangar shouldn't there be
security cameras in the hangar that
would see them rolling these
stormtroopers ah now there are security
cameras also they shoot them after
they've been recorded why didn't rages
use this Jedi mind trick on the two
guards walking up to the ship so they
can use their uniforms I know that would
be copying a new hope but as the only
logical move to make here you are
Republic interesting Palpatine [ __ ]
apparently are we going to go into how
this happened
No okay then all right then keep your
secrets
yeah nice weapon deserves more respect
what are you most afraid of myself
because you're a Palpatine ooh
Luke in the last Jedi had no idea who
Ray was but in the rise of Skywalker he
suddenly knows that she is a Palpatine
did Leia just join like the force ghost
group chat and tell Luke about Rey's
identity
not a single person shows up in the last
Jedi when the resistance lets out a
distress call in the rise of Skywalker
literally the whole galaxy shows up
Lando goes through a couple McDonnell
drive-throughs and somehow convinces
millions of people in the course of an
afternoon to join them
the main reason people didn't show up in
lost Jedi was because of fear now
Palpatine is back and you would think
that people would be even more scared
but that's just not the case are they
going to tell us who are what these
hooded figures are I assume they are
just sit force ghosts but the movie does
not go into it so whatever the Knights
are run were around the whole movie and
they get rolled in like 15 seconds like
they are literal Knights according to
their title but they can't win a 6v one
you can also see that some of the
Knights are just waiting around to
attack
like look at this kylo was literally
sitting still on his knees and the
knight misses his lower body
why doesn't Palpatine keep draining the
life out of Ray and Ben he can literally
just kill them on the spot but he
doesn't because of that thick and juicy
plot armor what is the answer - beating
Palpatine not one but two lightsabers
hell yeah
what a very creative solution so kylo
Ren goes through a big character arc and
becomes Ben solo again the sad thing is
is that he basically doesn't have any
lines of dialogue after this
transformation he just walks into XE
goal fight some people and then dies
like he's the most interesting character
and we don't get to see him as Ben solo
we're on the verge of crying this close
so for the new Star Destroyers with
planet killing weapons it apparently
only takes about 15 quick shots from a
y-wing to take them down that seems like
a pretty big design flaw this is
basically just the Death Star 4.0 but in
disguise
this point mostly goes into the tonal
whiplash from the movies cracked pacing
so let me lay out this scene for you Ben
solo a major character who has a strong
connection with Rey dies and we only get
a three-second reaction immediately
after this Rey just leaves in her x-wing
and she seems fine none of the other
characters bring up Ben solo or how he
made a sacrifice to save Rey he's just
forgotten just about as much time was
spent on snaps death scene and I bet you
don't even know who that is
[Music]
one point that I found while doing a
little research into the movie is that
Chris Terrio who is the top listed
writer was brought in to finish up the
scripts of JJ some other movies that
Chris Terrio was involved with writing
includes Batman V Superman and Justice
League I just don't understand why a
movie with one of the biggest budgets
would hire a guy who wrote two
blockbusters that were panned this could
very well be the guy who gave us the
martha line now he gave us this really
cringey line in the movie just overall
the rise of Skywalker is very
inconsistent in comparison to the last
Jedi and that was like a big reason why
I don't like it Luke isn't consistent
Finn lost purpose the shoehorn in
Palpatine because they lost Snoke and
even the scars on Colin's face are
inconsistent yeah that's about it
another point I was gonna go into was
Rey suddenly knowing how to force heal
when no other Jedi's knew how to but
it's Disney they'll create any plot
device to save their beloved characters
if this video does really well I could
probably make a Star Wars rise of
Skywalker but it's just bad dialogue
because there's a lot of bad lines in
the movie you know you are what you're
difficult really difficult difficult but
yeah hopefully has enjoyed the video and
have a nice day